I decided I should check on this
Greenland thing and make sure that hey
what if it's good maybe I should get
this deal done maybe the US could use
Greenland so here's what I did this past
weekend I decided to fly to Greenland on
behalf of the United States to make sure
personally that this purchase happens
yeah there you go thank you and I went
for my country and because things aren't
great at home anyway that's a
knee-slapper
anyway I brought a camera crew and it's
gonna be our new Konan Without Borders
special Conan in Bremen
Tuesday September 3rd 10 o'clock p.m. I
will tell you this that people of
Greenland are really lovely they've got
a great sense of humor they're fun
they're they're really good people and
the country itself is very beautiful and
so I had a bunch of adventures in the
very short time that I was there for
example while I was in Greenland I was
invited to drop by the local news studio
and that's an offer you can't turn down
not a big new studio very very small the
capital city Nokia is very very tiny I
stopped by their new studio and here's
what happened take a look commutes ever
come on mommy or no good often up master
no panel caucus out honest your is it
good evening I'm Tom O'Brien and I'm
bringing you the latest weather report
for Greenland I will give the report in
the Greenlandic language let's face it
how hard could it be a Pago are finan
Gangaram be so a summer ik Allah
Maserati Katella / 'it is Siegen a lorry
see ill olga Farney are signalling you
this unique so a stomach ill amasuite
ticket anna country miss Rama Turkey
Judy Akane illa book oops
sick Queen APOD Konami nya Montserrat
named Ivan Asura Teague konami dice
Aramis ooh ooh Louie in gorilla City
Casilla mix a karate master I do make
enough servicing in sacks for the chili
to get nice breakfast oh look his spear
is just cold stuff coming
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
thank you yeah that was really that went
out for real really yeah Wow no that's
not a joke I did that that went out and
then it appeared on TV that was the way
that was the weather report for
Greenland that night and I swear to God
I was walking through the trout town of
Nook afterwards and people were like saw
you do the way anyway it was a lot of
fun be sure to tune in to our Conan
agreement special airing this
[Applause]
you